Bill Gates is on another cover today and this is the cover of his very own book.
It's Gates' vision of what the next 20 years will bring.
It's called "The Road Ahead." Ladies and gentlemen,...
...please welcome Bill Gates, Bill!
I think if I'd known how much time it would take to write a book,...
...I might not have done a book.
This 1995 book projects a lot of changes driven by technology...
...and mostly I got a lot of things right.
What did you get right?
The internet would become more available.
"The global interactive network will transform our culture...
...as dramatically as Gutenberg's press did the Middle Ages."
You'll have electronic mail, you'll have videoconferencing,...
...so you can work out of your house.
The basic revolution that everything's connected...
...and how that's changed our world, that really did come true.
Once you have this small wallet PC, it'll replace almost everything you carry today.
What I called the wallet PC talked about what's become the miracle of the cell phone.
The pictures of your kids, it will store thousands and thousands of them for you.
That I got right.